you're approaching the political topics
that we're talking about and the
religious topics from a scientific place
right I sense that that really is the
bedrock of what you do as a scientist
that's what you're trying to quantify
and qualify all this stuff exactly and I
saw your interview with Bill Warner who
is also a scientist and a and a row he
studied all of the religions right he
said he studied with Imams he studied
the Quran and he studied with rabbis in
Jerusalem the Old Testament all that and
and I thought he said something very
similar that as he's looking at these
things as a scientist not as a
sociologist exactly and do you think
that's really the healthiest way to
exactly boaty dissent and actually
that's one of the reasons why I mean of
course I receive negative comments from
people and hate mail and so on yeah but
given the types of positions I take
they're actually quite quick few of them
precisely because I approach it in the
manner that I do right so whenever I
take a position I make sure that it is
documented as it would be if I were
submitting a paper to a scientific
journal right so my my evidentiary
threshold is set so high that it becomes
difficult to you know break it down
right and therefore people can accuse me
of hate speech and this and that because
everything is backed up in the case of
Bill Warner for the viewers who may not
know this yeah
he basically applied the tools of
content analysis to then quantify the
amount of hate that is found in
different different religious texts so
we don't have to have a you know a
vacuous discussion about whether Islam
is peaceful or not whether the Old
Testament is peaceful or not I can
actually use the tools of science in
this case called the content analysis to
quantify how much hate there is in this
book right and and that becomes
unassailable well so with the assailable
party though that what's in the book is
only only matters depending on the
amount of people that act on it right so
that's not that's not unassailable in
its in its scientific method but that's
what the real issue is right the real
issue is not what's in all these books
right as much as how many people are
acting on it that sounded almost reza
aslan ish to me did it no get me out of
that we cut because
I I fully I mean look we know these book
is not right they're all filled by
written by men thousands of years ago
but it's not really what's in them as
much as how people act on them well so
reza aslan basically use the the worst
thing anyone my deep apology Reza Aslan
basically used the BS argument from
post-modernism to say you put your
meaning right exactly so you know who
are we to judge whether kill kill kill
means that kill kill kill could mean a
stroke with kindness and that's right no
it doesn't okay yeah language has
accepted meaning and a no amount of
postmodern gymnastics is going to alter
that right so I guess what I I think
what I was saying is that if you looked
at the three books and you I think by
most accounts that the Old Testaments
probably the most violent of them but no
one really acting on the violence of
that so that doesn't discount that it
says some horrible stuff but if nobody's
acting on it then it's sort of
irrelevant so I hope I hope that's not
postmodern cuz I know I know that exact
quote from him and it sounds like purely
well yeah so we can get into the
theological discussion I mean one of the
for example if in the Old Testament says
killed the alumnae kites
yeah well they don't exist anymore so
even if I was desperate to act on that
edict I wouldn't be able to on the other
hand if a another religious book has the
following tenant killed the
non-believers wherever you find them
that is actionable today so so no the
argument that well it depends who acts
on it is not true there's very plus we
don't have many people today that act on
Deuteronomy right well that that was my
point that it depends on who's acting on
it but that doesn't change the the
specifics exact better that are in the
text are enough do you find that as an
academic and as a social scientist and
all that that it's exhausting talking
about religion because you don't believe
in it so that you know you mean like
you're trying to add something rational
this is what I I'm constantly trying to
rationalize things that cannot be
rationalized anymore and actually also
in your discussion with Bill Warner he
said one of the interesting things about
the Quran is you can almost rationalize
anything yes
you can say something's really great
logic yeah do so can you explain to a
logical level yeah so the idea is so
people don't know that the Koran has
what's called abrogated verses so God
might have decided through the
revelations to say there's no compulsion
in religion and then later God is
allowed to change his mind and say kill
you know don't be so tolerant right
right
well how could it be that a and not a
can coexist well through a logic that
can be allowed and the way you do that
is through abrogation which basically
means that when you have two texts that
contradict one another the later text
the text supersedes the previous one so
when people typically quote the gentle
passages from the Quran that's the
Meccan period those passages have
actually been abrogated they've been
made null and void so now in some cases
the people who who quote those passages
know this and they are actually being
duplicitous in other cases they're
unaware of this abrogation mechanism all
right so let's just talk about Reza for
a minute since you brought him up and he
because he's become such a player in
this space and CNN's even giving him a
show all about belief which sounds just
horrific to me when he plays those games
you know right you know that he knows
this he knows about what you just
described
and yet he's doing this so what do we do
with these players you know what do we
do it's a great question because I I
don't know what his endgame is I mean is
it is it that he's engaging in
self-deception as we know humans are
very adept at doing there's actually
some very interesting evolutionary
arguments for why people engage in
self-deception yeah want me to take off
yeah let's go there okay so so the
argument for the evolution of
self-deception is that when you and I
are chatting we're engaging if you like
an immaculate battle I'd like to get you
to do what I want but I don't want you
to know that I'm doing this right so
when I'm lying to you there are
typically markers and me that you're
trying to pick up to see if I'm being
duplicitous and or not the way that I
shut off those markers is by first
convincing myself that I'm not lying in
other words by engaging in
self-deception I shut off the mechanisms
that you might otherwise read in me that
I'm lying
interesting so but is that a fully
conscious decision on the part of the
that's doing it no no it's not it's an
evolutionary mechanism that's been built
into us now so right you know sign on
Seinfeld there's a classic episode where
George Costanza says to Jerry I might
get the quote wrong remember Jerry it's
not a lie if you believe it yeah I
actually talked about this in one of my
earlier books well that's that's the
idea so so I don't know and Reza's case
whether he truly believes the the just
the endless tsunami of nonsense that he
produces or whether it's just a
duplicitous attempt you know this is the
way by which I've become very famous
this is the way by which I get a lot of
attention because I'm sort of the brown
guy from Iran who could appear moderate
and so on and I'm gonna stick to that
niche because it's got to me a lot of
Fame so I can't tell which of these two
possibilities he's under you know it's
so interesting because when I hear you
say that
it clearly comes from a place where
you're trying to give him the benefit of
the doubt right you just went out of
your way to not say this guy is a
duplicitous liar or whatever and you
know sam Harris oh he says how
intentions matter right and you're
trying to say well maybe his intentions
are good so that would be a reason to
you know fiddle with some of this right
stuff I sense that all the people that
that we argue with all the time they
would not give us any of those yes asses
and that to me shows you where this
battle really has happened right that
there's there's kind of a an immediate
reflex to label anybody who's in our
space you know a Nazi and Hitler and
Himmler right that's right
yeah I agree I mean I've been fortunate
again knock on wood that I haven't had
too much of this stuff maybe because I
am quite measured in how I speak and
maybe because I come from that
background it gives me a layer of
protection which maybe Sam can't have
yeah I'm not exactly sure but I've been
fortunate in that sense right so too
much what my question that started this
whole thing using scientific method to
discuss texts not this text right but
religious texts that aren't necessarily
based in rationality or in secular
values do you find it exhausting
I mean having right like or do you find
yourself spending a lot of time
deciphering thing is that we shouldn't
be worried about anymore and we don't
worry about what scientists thought
3,000 years ago so why are we worried
about what religious people thought 3000
sex or ordinary right because if if you
take a belief that someone holds and you
don't cloak it under the robe of
religion then this would be tantamount
to the guy being schizophrenic and let's
commit him to a mental hospital right
right but we can give a good example of
that because I think that's a really
great point uh okay so this prophet has
gone on a winged horse somewhere yeah if
I say that hey you know I believe that
Dave Rubin yesterday I saw him on a
winged horse going to to heaven yeah
then we're good mushrooms then I would
call my clinical psychologist or
psychiatrist friends and say hey let's
try to commit Dave Rubin to a
psychiatric hospital on the other hand
if I say the exact same thing but it is
cloaked under a religious narrative
don't you dare criticize that narrative
right so the exact same statement is
either a form of lunacy or perfectly
acceptable religion wrap ending on
whether it is protected by religion and
that's grotesque right I mean why is
your belief in whatever narrative you
choose to believe somehow sacrosanct and
I can't touch it yeah so when it comes
to religion and obviously we've spent a
lot of time talking about this and I've
had mostly people that are anti religion
but just last week I had altra or not
ultra Orthodox but Orthodox Jew Benjamin
cilantro yes who I thought made some
pretty cogent arguments separating
religion from politics even though I
didn't agree with him on a lot of it but
I thought he did an interesting you know
he wasn't trying to govern I sense I'm a
place of religion which I could at least
respect that but what do you make of the
general feeling that you know you watch
the Super Bowl in the second Super Bowl
and they thank God yes these are people
who spend their entire lives training
right to become machines of athleticism
and the team that lost God also but also
prayed to the same guy yeah but somehow
God really was for the Cardinals so he
hates the Trailblazers I mix expose you
make sport day
I really I really do know sports more
than that but I'm trying to think of
your lawyer yeah so but but to me that
what that shows is not a belief in God
per se as much as it shows almost a
narcissistic disorder the lord of the
universe and i mean if only people would
have a sense of the vastness of the
universe uniquely cares about a point
guard who's about to make a three-point
closing shot yeah and if he makes it Oh
Lord Jesus thank you I mean Jesus must
really be invested in your career stats
yeah and by the way we can also take
examples it would be like you know if
you jerked off or something and then
felt guilty after because God was
watching you it's like he's watching you
do that he's watching basketball better
things if you I mean really if without
even my like I know it there's a certain
mocking tone here but without even
mocking it if you if you really believed
in this wouldn't you believe that God
would be doing something else reading
another universe you know I mean really
otherwise it seems so silly yeah right
he's quite pedantic ya know but I'll
give you I I did a a actually it's in
this book where I played this following
a mental game suppose you had a Martian
who came to earth and he's shopping for
the one true religion and so he asks a
bunch of questions am I allowed to wear
leather shoes can I have a tattoo am I
allowed to be to have homosexual
relations I mean you think from the most
mundane yeah to the most metaphysical
questions I demonstrated that for every
possible question that you can generate
I can identify two religions that
prescribe the exact opposite thing to
that same question I mean if that
doesn't serve as a devastating blow to
the whole scam of religion nothing goes
right right let's put it another way
there are 10,000 documented religions in
the world I bet you about that 10,000
yeah now hear what I mean is different
denominations of Christianity with
countless different religions right so
there are 10,000 of them the only thing
that they typically have in common is
that each of them says that I'm the true
religion the other 9999 are false
incredible that sounds a bit fishy to me
right and also there
that they're all designed differently I
find that when I'm when we're debating a
lot of this stuff you know especially
with I have we've gone almost 40 minutes
and haven't said regressives so I'm
finally going to say the word
aggressives and regressive left that
they always want everything to be
equally as bad right except some
religions want people to convert into
them some don't right that would show
that not that it's necessarily better
but it would show that certain people
don't want to spread their ideas as much
as other people but there is a need on
the left to go ah everything's really is
bad and once you do that you're actually
saying nothing right I've actually used
that same argument but in the under the
context of an academic setting so
there's there's a concept known as a
meme are you familiar with that of
course so this is Richard Dawkins right
well Richard Dawkins argues that
religion is a Mima plex it's a
collection of memes and memes spread
very much like how viruses spread or how
genes propagate in populations well or
how memes spread on Twitter right how
things are exactly so to go to your
point about religions some religions the
the content of their memes are
inherently infectious in other words the
transmissibility of that religion is
much greater so in Judaism the fact that
you you don't proselytize is precisely
the reason why there are 13 14 15
million Jews depending on how you count
right in the whole entire universe there
are 15 million Jews on the other hand in
a religion where you're allowed to
Priscilla ties and there are other
things that you can do also for example
it takes very little to get into the
religion in Islam for example right yeah
and Judaism if you truly wish to convert
according to the strict tenants you
can't just sort of say one sentence and
boom welcome to the right of the Jewish
clan right yeah you actually have to go
through a very costly process so there
are all sorts of mechanisms that you
could study in the context of a religion
that demonstrate why one spreads and
another one doesn't right and by the way
using the example that you just
mentioned it's also a lot to get out of
Judaism you could say I'm not a Jew
anymore nobody cares but if you were to
get out of Islam we know this with
apostates all over the world you might
get killed oh no but to kill means to
caress or your job the sounders problem
right so okay we take all of this we get
it you think that this this mode of
thinking is
is not great for the world and and all
of that you want to use things from a
scientific place so when I had Peter
Bogosian on he wrote a book called a
manual for creating atheists yes and I
read it and I thought it was really
great book and I've tried to use some of
those practices when I've talked to
people about this stuff and I asked him
does he think that like what's the
difference at the end of the day if
someone holds some of these beliefs but
isn't doing anything nefarious and isn't
pushing these ideas on anyone do you
still think it's bad and he basically
said yes because he said I'm not quoting
him exactly but that you're diluting
yourself and that's not really with the
point of being human is right what would
you say in that case if someone just
picked some beliefs it's nominal in
question nobody cares you know you're
not oppressing someone or making women
dress a certain way right so I don't
know so it depends if I want to be
pragmatic or a purist if I want to be
pragmatic I say you don't believe
whatever you want as long as you don't
impose your beliefs on third parties
then I don't care so that's the magnetic
part yeah if I were to be a purist right
at the pursuit of truth matters then I
would agree then with Peter that to
believe in these types of fairy tales is
actually injurious to the human spirit
right so that in and of itself even if
it's not propagating violence or
something on someone else that it's
against the sort of human nature right
something like and if anything I mean
and many atheists have have talked about
this there is a wonder that you can
access without needing religion what
what religion does in a sense is it is
it is it covers the capacity I mean I
can go and see a beautiful landscape and
be transcended transcended by the
experience without needing booga-booga
to - for me to actually experience that
right so it's actually cheap in his life
to always have to contextualize it
within the context of a Big Daddy in the
sky that's interesting yeah I think I've
told the story on the show once before
but I once ate pop brownies and I was
going to see Air Force one with some
friends and it was sold out so we we
went and saw contact
did you see contact yeah this is what
the saucer and it was written it was
Carl Sagan's only fiction book
and I didn't know what the movie was at
all I had no idea what we were walking
into and now if you remember but the
opening scene was this incredible
panorama of the universe and I ate these
pop rounds I was basically like tripping
out of my mind and the whole movie just
blew my mind apart I was like this is
amazing either reading a whole bunch of
Carl's rights books and all that and it
sort of led me to a lot of the things
that I think now but the movie ends she
has this sort of not that satisfying
experience because she can't prove that
what happened to her actually happened
and the movie ends with her just looking
out on a sunset and that's exactly what
you're saying that there are ways to I
suppose feel connected and feel a part
of this thing that don't necessarily
absolutely and now standing up and
sitting a lot at a actually that was one
of the starting points that got me away
from religion we were sitting at a
synagogue mcgann Avraham and Beirut okay
and I asked my father you know I'm
confused when do we stand up when do we
sit down and he's like you don't shut up
just the fact that he said that really
upsets me because already as I don't
remember how old I was maybe five six
seven
that left a hole in me what you mean why
am I just standing up and sitting down
to give me an explanation yeah so the
fact that there was sort of this this
dogmatism is probably the starting point
of what led me astray from religion but
to come back to atheism I've written an
article in on my Psychology Today blog
where I talked about carpe diem right
seizing the day and that atheism is
really consistent with that ethos right
of living in the moment right there are
no do-overs
there is no eternal life it's now right
it's the relationship that I form now
it's the it's the knowledge that I
helped spread now it's the goodness that
I can impart to the world and so that
actually makes it a much more wonderful
experience to realize that you have a
very short limited time now of course
it's very scary right I mean you and I
want this party to go on forever yeah
and that's why I think actually that
religion will never cease to exist
we'll never eradicate it because we will
never resolve the problem of our
existential angst right so when you say
the word eradicate there I know that the
the regressives who have launched this
huge assault on new atheist they sort of
came up with this term new atheist and I
guess originally it had to do with
Hitchens and Sam and Daniel Dennett I
think and who is the fourth I think
there was a fourth in there somehow
Oh Richard Dawkins versus Arkansas um
but the idea that these people these New
Atheists
they're not just atheists who believe
whatever the hell they want to believe
they want to destroy religion and I
think they've spread this meme yes as a
way of silencing people who would
critique right that to me is all they've
done here because I have no I know many
many atheists I know no atheist that is
trying to use violence or intimidation
in any way to stop anyone right from
believing anything sure they may
critique you if they ridicule you why
should they be quiet but why should they
be quiet - of your religion at me all
day long I should I should be quiet in
my non-belief why I mean I'm not
suggesting that you should ever be
impolite I mean you could be nice and
you could be polite about it but I have
to be quiet I was all quiet when I was
living as a Jew in Lebanon I want to be
quiet anymore so that's so that's really
interesting so that the all it is when
they say new atheist all they mean
really is an atheist who speaking up and
that's what that's what they hate more
than have you seen some of my satirical
tweets about new atheism I'm sure I've
said so I wait to 100 pounds then I put
on 10 pounds I'm now a new atheist yeah
I used to have this skin tone then I
went on vacation I became the new
atheist is a term that's complete
nonsense
yeah alright so we're going to do a
little more of the the regressive stuff
when we sit down with with Lalo in a
little bit but I'm just curious for you
personally as you've been part of this
discussion and again we just sat down
for the first time in August so we only
met about eight months ago I probably
only knew of you on Twitter for maybe
three four months before that as you've
become part of this I'm curious how much
of it
how much Jake consumes you actually like
that because I know how personal this is
to me I know that I have trouble
shutting it off sometimes at night and I
don't mean just my phone I mean just the
thought process and feeling that that
there is something big going on here
that we're part of
how big does it feel to it very big and
often I mean I would say that the last
six months I've spent maybe 50% of my
time working on these types of issues as
opposed to say Mike sort of classic
scientific career yeah precisely because
I if you like I define my role more
broadly than just as somebody who's a
professor right I mean I can engage the
public in the battle of ideas and and
frankly I'm quite disappointed in many
of my colleagues who don't think that
way right I mean nobody is contesting
the fact that it's really important to
do your great basic science I mean
that's that's what you are your
professor your scientists but if you've
got the capacity to reason then it is it
is important for you to also participate
in battles of ideas that are outside
your very limited
you know lab studies right and so in
that sense I actually have been quite
consumed by some of the issues you're
not where I sometimes regret my
participation is when I don't know when
to stop aging some ass who's constantly
hounding me now in many cases I'm able
to disengage but in a few times they
kind of they trigger you in some way and
then you engage this person you realize
you just wasted an hour and a half
speaking to somebody who's in his
underwear in his mom's basement yeah all
right well I'm going to dive more into
that with you in lalo a little bit all
right so look we could talk forever and
this is my second interview in a row
where I haven't even picked up my my
notes once but because I started by
talking about college and that's what
you just brought this at you what's the
hope give me give me the hope point for
some of this turning now I get we can
talk about this stuff and I we see it
that there is this now movement growing
of people that aren't afraid of speaking
and all that stuff well how do you as a
professor feel that you can win this did
you feel it right it's it's precisely
and empowering every single individual
to engage the debate right I receive
endless private messages from people
whom I've never met them I'll never see
again so you know just because I watch
how you behave and how much you've got
to lose professionally and if not also
personally I mean in terms of threats
and so on this has gotten me the courage
to speak out against some of my
regressive
friends on Facebook and I just spent
three hours taking on these guys and I
wouldn't have done it had I not seen
your courage so basically all you're
trying to do is to empower people to
feel as though they can make a
difference and by having enough of them
because think about it the regressive
left is quite invested in this fight
yeah and all you need to do is stand up
and offer a counterpoint and get enough
people to do it truth is on our side we
will win yeah so that's what enrages
them more than anything else to wrap
this up that's what enrages them is that
they've been sort of unchecked exists
all time right like because they were
because the right in a lot of respects
has gone off the deep end so that there
was no rational argument to be had now
here come us and it's like oh they we're
gonna have some rational arguments but
they've been doing the whole cries of
race is not a monopoly yeah if I don't
happily and there's a new company that's
offering another product they're not
happy yeah well we're gonna beat them
with better ideas what do you will we
will let's do it all right well it was a
pleasure talking to you it's of course
and for more of God's head you can
follow him on twitter at dads at his
youtube channel is in the description
below and there is something big coming
we're going to be working together
pretty soon we're going to discuss that
with Lalo thanks for watching and we'll
do it again next week